how's it going Brad as my name's Peter
today I'm here where we're gonna do the
volcano making thing I always see it in
movies all the kids do it I never
actually see one to actually do it
I think it's an American thing but it
says here make a 10 centimeter tall
volcano that's this tall paint and
decorate it
I'm thinking I always wanted to decorate
my volcano amaze your friends and family
with the bubbly fizzy lava eruption it's
an awesome science project and a cool
desktop decoration I can't yet
the way I keep doing Eddie do we need
any extra thing I have no idea I would
think that you would need baking soda no
I think you have all this stuff oh you
can even paint it oh my god this is the
bulky oh yeah we gonna put it on this is
your coke stash hidings fine
this is your pain this is your crochet
more cookie scrappy okay
rubber bands cuz you never know when you
need those and I think I don't know what
you don't make out with about you know
please
safety messages cuz safety first please
read through the insert don't put the ad
the cocaine in your nose or throat
and that's it you see the outside with
the outside would be the inside of this
volcano it's kind of like life Oh
so we're making this thing and making
the thing oh I did not expect I thought
we would just think these and oh no no
we we uh whoa you get stickers - Tim
agenda look at the people running it's
gonna be awesome
you will need a mixing bowl scissors for
the background now I'm just confused
right
we need vinegar and baking soda Elsa we
they because they react together that's
what will create devour do we have a
yeah I'll have to run out and get it I
used to have vinegar until today's
internet giveaway why would you throw
away vinegar music got smelly more
vinegar Oh seriously I can't really have
agendas here are you making me favor
oh god it's below don't smell it Maya
you could get sick okay you have never
done one of these oh you haven't been
either I haven't done a volcano but I
have done all this before
are you alone making pancakes makin
bacon pancakes all right we're done what
do we do now
drink it now we put it in here or you
can see what it looks delicious it looks
like a cake
get enough bro this is our first full
keynote this failed that I don't even
know went out yeah what yeah it's
leaking yeah yeah it's leaking what are
you gonna do life is leaking sometimes
too but that doesn't mean you cry over
it wait okay scissor you will have to
see you in 20 minutes I will go buy
vinegar you will make sure stairs Sarah
it went instantly yeah blinky put my ass
I only 202 tan how'd we sit are you
scared
still ski and well well great movies
will be half what do you know how to do
this yeah you can totally see be you
know you know we're gonna paint it can i
screen it now it looks beautiful
or but I couldn't do the inhabitants
vinegar this is the my life has led up
to this moment literally all right you
ready brass okay
volcana powwow I'm freaking out over
here nothing is happening
come on it's blow of bubbles if I wanted
to make a move if I wanted to make a
bubble bath Wow oh my god alright easy
okay uh everything went backwards oh my
god that was amazing
you we are not worthy blue gotta defin
step did anyone die everyone is fine now
actually
dangerous no thanks the wrong vinegar
that's pretty lame it was awesome you
would keep this under desk like yeah I'm
a dad
Oh keep it my case I can put make a
brush in on it brushes on it that's
pretty good you know what
leave a like in the comment and you get
a chance to win this book which is cited
in the back here we didn't actually
paint babies very easy so let's get our
nice beside it okay yeah I'm not ok our
signatures in the back thank you for
watching this episode if you learn
something new then you're welcome and
we'll see you in the next one
brofist oh yeah try number 2 with a
different vinegar